but I was awake I need help you almost  broke the internet when you said you're  going to be stepping away from Rea miss  close it was a miss okay let's clear it  out what is well know firstly that was  at the end of a very long day that end  of a very long shoot it was pouring it  down with rain in Montreal we were  talking about where the the trilogy is  going wherever it is all I said was as  far as I was concerned when I signed on  I was signing on to seven eight nine I  don't know about any plans building that  that's for Disney that's about anyone  else in charge he was into it and well  in my mind that is where the story ends  and I think that's where everyone for  now Marx talked about it the trilogy's  represent a beginning a middle and an  end but I don't know last remark though  because he came no exam probably thought  that exactly but also Star Wars works in  three is anyway so um so yeah that was  misquoted okay so there is a possibility  yeah you know  [Music]